TREY: WELCOME BACK TO
"SUNDAY NIGHT IN AMERICA"
SENATOR PAT TOOMEY WON TWICE
STATED WIDE AS A REPUBLICAN
IN PENNSYLVANIA, THEY WERE
BOTH TOUGH, HARD RACES, NOW
THE STATE FROM PAT TOOM TO
PAT TOOMEY TO JOHN
FETTERMAN, SENATOR TOOMEY IS
JOINING US NOW.
YOU WON TWICE, IF I RECALL
BOTH WERE TOUGH, HARD RACES.
HOW DID YOU SUCCEED WHERE
DR. OZ AND OTHERS WERE NOT
ABLE TO?
>> WELL, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
MY RACES WERE CLOSE, THEY
WERE TIGHT, I WON BY 2% OF
FIRST TIME, LESS THAN THAT
THE SECOND.
I THINK THAT STORY OF THIS
ELECTION CYCLE WAS FLAWED
CANDIDATES.
AT THE TOP OF TICKET IN
PENNSYLVANIA, WE HAD A
GUBERNATORIAL NOMINEE, WHO
LOST BY 15 POINTS.
THAT IS WORST BEAT DOWN
WE'VE HAD IN AN OPEN SEAT
RACE IN PENNSYLVANIA SINCE
1950s.
AND YOU KNOW I THINK THAT
DR. OZ WAS A GOOD CANDIDATE,
BUT HE COULD NOT OVERCOME
THAT AHEAD WIND, WE GOT
WITHIN 3 1/2.
WHICH IS A HECK OF A LOT
CLOSER THAN WAS TO OF THE
TICKET.
BUT IT WAS TOO MUCH
HEADWIND, IT COST US, I
THINK 3 HOUSE SEATS WE WERE
VERY COMPETITIVE.
LET'S REMEMBER.
YOU DON'T GET AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT IS
MORE FAVORABLE THAN THIS,
WHEN A SPECTACULAR FAILURE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN, PEOPLE SEE THAT GET
THAT, YET THEY STILL VOTED
AGAINST US IN PENNSYLVANIA.
WE HAD SOME BRIGHT SPOTS IN
THE NATION AND OTHER STATES
FLORIDA THE LEADING EXAMPLE.
BUT IT WAS A LONG PAINFUL
NIGHT IN PENNSYLVANIA.
TREY: YOU KNOW SENATOR, YOU
PUT YOUR FINGER ON ALMOST
EVERY CONCEIVABLE TAILWIND
SEEMED TO BE WITH THE
REPUBLICANS.
YOU MENTIONED YOUR
GUBERNATORIAL CANDIDATE.
I GUESS THOSE OF US WHO
DON'T LIVE IN PENNSYLVANIA,
HOW DID HE WIN THE
NOMINATION?
WERE THERE OTHER -- WAS IT
CLOSE?
HOW DID YOU FACTOR GENERAL
ELECTION ELECTABILITY?
>> THAT WAS NOT
CONSIDERATION IN HIS
PRIMARY.
I THINK MOST PEOPLE THAT I
TALKED TO REALIZED HE WAS
VERY DUBIOUS CANDIDATE FOR
THE GENERAL ELECTION.
HE WAS PERCEIVED AS BEING
VERY CLOSE TO DONALD TRUMP.
HE HAD RECRUITED SCHOOL
BUSES TO GO TO JANUARY 6
RALLY, AND SAID THINGS ABOUT
HOW HE WOULD BE ABLE TO
APPOINT A SECRETARY OF STATE
WITH -- THAT
--
>> HE GOT 40 PERCENT OF THE
VOTE IN PRIMARY, BUT CLEAR
HE WOULD BE UNALLEGED IN
GENERAL ELECTION, THAT IS
WHAT HAPPENED.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS PLAY OUT
IN OTHER STATES.
CANDIDATES THAT WERE SEEN AS
ULTRA ALL ABOUT THE PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT, AND RELITIGATING
THE LAST ELECTION, THEY WENT
DOWN IN FLAMES, EVEN IN MANY
CASES WHERE CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICANS WERE WINNING
BIG, NEW HAMPSHIRE, GEORGIA,
FLORIDA.
-- FLORIDA NO, IT WAS
SUCCESSFUL THERE IN OHIO,
J.D. VANCE MANAGED TO WIN BY
ONLY 6 OR 7 POINTS AND
DeWINE WAS WINNING BY 25,
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT ELECT
BILL TIE, CREDIBILITY OF
CANDIDATES AND LOYALTY TO
DONALD TRUMP IS NOT A
SUFFICIENT CRITERIA.
TREY: ALL RIGHT, SENATOR YOU
SAID DR. OZ RAN A GOOD
CAMPAIGN, IT WAS MUCH CLOSER
THAN THE GUBERNATORIAL RACE.
BUT, WERE THERE CANDIDATES
IN SENATE PRIMARY THAT YOU
THINK MAY HAVE FARED BETTER
IN THE GENERAL ELECTION OR
WOULD THE FACE WIN OF
GOVERNOR CANDIDATE HAVE
STOPPED ANY OF THE PRIMARY
CONSIDERATIONS FOR YOUR
SEAT?
>> YOU KNOW, WE'LL NEVER
KNOW, PRIMARY CAME DOWN TO A
ABOUT THE EP BATTLE BETWEEN
DR. OZ AND DAVE McCORMACK.
IT IS NOT OBVIOUS TO HE
WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WIN
WHEN THE TOP OF THE TICKET
IS LOSING BY 15 POINTS, IT
IS YOU KNOW, UNKNOWABLE.
AGAIN, I THINK IMPORTANT
THING IS THAT DR. OZ WAS A
GOOD CANDIDATE, RAN A GOOD
RACE, AND STILL CAME
UP SHORT IN A YEAR WHERE WE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN CLEANING
HOUSE.
TREY: YOU ARE TOO YOUNG TO
RETIRE, BUT WHAT ARE YOU
DOING WHEN YOU LEAD THE
SENATE.
>> I HAVE TO FIGURE THAT OUT
IN JANUARY, I HAVE NOTHING
LINED UP, BY DESIGN, I AM
WAITING, I HOPE TO HAVE A
LOT OF THINGS TO CONSIDER
AND PURSUE COME THE NEW
YEAR.
TREY: WE'D LOVE TO HAVE YOU
MOVE TO SOUTH CAROLINA.
I'LL SHOW YOU ALL OF OUR
GOLF COURSES, THANK YOU FOR
JOINING